Cuz I'm Muslim. Alhamdulillah. How do
you know? How do you know that being
Muslim is the right path? I'm proud to
be Muslim. How do you know that being
Muslim is the right path? Is it because
Muhammad calls you
halfbrain? She left
too. Tough guys. You guys are in front
of thousands of people, man. You guys
have an opportunity, a golden
opportunity to tell me why Islam is the
straight path. You know how Jesus
preached Islam.
golden opportunity
here. You know what I'm saying? I'm
trying to give you guys a chance to give
give some good dah here. Let's go.
Islamic content. Maybe this should be
good. I'm a little I'm a little scared
though. Islamic content. How you doing?
Um, yo, bro, I want to ask you a
question, right? Did Jesus preach
Christianity or Islam, my brother?
Islam. How do you know that?
uh because like so basically uh it says
in the Quran he did and some parts of
the Bible Jesus said he wasn't uh we
should pray we should worship God right
yeah he also said that we should worship
him too so no he didn't that the the
Bible the Bible is corrupted though oh
but you quoted from the Bible you just
quoted from the Bible that said where
Jesus says worship God. So is that
corrupted?
So basically, okay, if if Jesus if Jesus
said you're missing it. You just quoted
the Bible in saying that Jesus preached
Islam because he said to worship God. I
just gave you also a Bible verse and
then you said the Bible's corrupted. So
why are you quoting a corrupted book to
prove that Jesus? No. No. Listen. So, so
basically the Bible, right? Part of it
is
corrupted. Are you listening? But I want
to ask you a question. But the Quran,
the Quran says you can't do that. The
Quran says that you have to believe in
all of the scripture. You can't believe
in part of it and reject the other parts
or else you're going to go to hell.
That's chapter 2 verse 85. But the same
Quran, listen, but the same Quran told
us that it was uh people changed it. Oh.
So then the same Quran told us that.
Okay. So is your Quran confirming a
corrupted book?
Yeah. The Quran confirmed the Bible and
the Torah, right? But the same Quran
told us that some part of it. Yeah. So
the Quran, just to be clear, the Quran
is confirming. Now, I would have brought
I would have brought out my book on you,
but somebody's already said this before
you, so I can't even I can't repeat the
statement. But just to be clear, the
Quran is confirming a corrupted book. Is
that correct?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. The the Quran.
So basically, say it again louder
because like I don't think people my my
audience listen listen. So basically we
believe we believe we believe right?
Yeah. Go ahead. I'm sorry. We believe uh
we believe that the Quran, right, was
sent to Muhammad and the gospel was sent
to Jesus. What? And then I didn't know
that. Torah and the Torah was sent to
Moses, right? What? How you know that?
Because the Quran said it. Show me. Show
me where the Quran says the Torah was
sent to Moses.
What is it? Okay.
We believe.
Gonna get some we believe shirts, but
I'm afraid we'll get copyrighted by
Golden State Warriors. Y'all remember
the We Believe
era. Muslims love that Golden State era.
For the Golden State Warriors, they had
the We believe shirts. We
believe. I think a Muslim made that
shirt for the for the
team. The We believe
shirts. If I create a new Tik Tok
uh Tik Tok profile, it might be named We
Believe. Go ahead. Yo, can you hear me,
bro? Can you hear me? I can hear you
now. All right. I can only hear you if
you're on if you're on the on Tik Tok. I
can't hear you if you're off the app.
Uh you go to Quran 7 uh what was it
called? 7 uh Quran verse 7.145.
7145.
Yes. And
no 144. 714. And in 7144 it says that
the Torah was given to
Moses again. If you're off the app, I
can't hear you.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. 714. All right. I'm
here. All right. It says this. It says
um said I think Allah said, "Oh Moses, I
have chosen you over the people with my
messages and my words. So take what I
have given you and be among the
grateful."
I didn't see any Torah being mentioned
there.
Okay. All right. So, go to Surah 11. All
right. But hold on. This verse that we
just read, it didn't say anything about
the Torah, right? Bro, but it says he
sent a book to Moses. Yeah, but what was
that book?
Torah? Where does it say that,
bro? Okay. Okay. If you want
understanding, just go to 11 11. All
right. So, just All right. So, just to
be clear, you're about to show me the
verse where it says that the book given
to Moses is the Torah.
Bro, bro, just go to 11 before I before
I go there, cuz trust me, I I I have no
problem going wherever you want me to
go. I'm following your lead. But for me
to follow your lead, I have to trust
that you're not misguiding me. You know
what I'm saying? So I just want to be
clear. Is chapter 11 verse 111 or
whatever you said. Is that verse going
to say that the Torah was given to
Moses?
Kind of. Just go there. Kind of. Kind
of. Man, we don't work on kindas. We
don't work on may and know that's Islam.
That's why you know all I be saying
maybe this and maybe that and you know
that's not how I work on man. Okay. But
but the Quran says uh what was it
called? It says about something about
scriptures and what just just go there
and read it to people. Just just just
go. I'm not about to read the people a
waste of a verse that waste our time. We
want a verse that says that the Torah
was given to Moses. If you don't have
that, brother, just say that. It's okay,
bro. Just read it, man. Just read it
because you know that you're going to
find something there. You just you don't
want to trust it, man. I'm going trust
you. All right. Go read. So, it's
chapter 11 verse what?
Uh 110. All right. Chapter 11, verse
110. All right, guys. You ready? This
verse is going to be the verse that
tells us that the Torah was given to
Moses. Okay? And it reads, matter of
fact, let me put on the screen so we can
all see
it. And we have certainly given Moses
the scripture.
All right. But it came under
disagreement.
All right. Let me just finish the verse
because maybe maybe it'll say that the
scripture that he got was the Torah. So
maybe because it didn't say that there,
but maybe it might say it after. And if
not for a word that preceded from your
Lord, it would have been judged between
them. And indeed they are concerning the
Quran in disquing
doubt. Disquing,
right? That's a beautiful word. All
right. So I just read the verse that you
really wanted me to read.
And as I read the verse, it says that
Moses was given a scripture, but it
doesn't tell me what that scripture is.
Bro, come on, bro. Come on. Why are you
trying to Why are you trying to Why are
you trying to change this? Why am I
trying to hold you to your words? Okay,
one sec. One sec. One sec. So, it says
the the scriptures was given to Moses,
right? It says the scripture was given
to Moses. Which scripture?
The Torah. The Torah was given. Show,
brother. I'm giving you a chance. Show
me where it says the Torah is that
scripture that was given to Moses.
That's all I want.
So, look, I'm giving you a hint. Do not
do not tell me that Moses don't show me
where it says Moses was given a book,
where Moses is given a scripture, where
Moses is given a message. I don't care
about all none of that. I know he was
given a scripture, a book or a message.
I know that. What I need besides a beat
that super dumping is for the verse in
the Quran to identify the scripture,
message or book that Muham that Moses
was given as the Torah. Where does it do
that?
So basically basically right if like uh
basically uh like um I I don't even know
how to explain it, bro. Like the Quran
literally tells us about the Moses and
the Torah where so basically where where
it tells us
about bro let me explain let me explain
no I don't brother respectfully Islamic
content I do not need your explanation I
only need you to read that's the only
thing I like to do here the only thing I
like to do I don't like to explain stuff
I don't like to interpret stuff I only
like to read and and I like my guests to
read. So, just read me the verse where
it says that the Torah is the book that
was given to Moses. That's all you need.
Just read that. I don't need anything
explained. If you don't have that, then
say, you know what, Avery, my fault.
You're right. Um, it doesn't say that in
the in the Quran. I don't know where I
got that from.
Okay. Okay. Can Can I ask you one
question? Sure. Just one question. Sure.
Do do you believe in the Torah? Yes.
And uh who who do you think the Torah
was? That's enough. No, I'm asking.
That's enough now. Now shut. What do you
mean that's enough? So look look I
promise you. Look look look listen
listen. Islamic content. I'm a I'm a
chill dude. You can ask me whatever you
want. whatever you want as after you
either one show me the verse where in
the Quran it identifies the Torah as the
book given to Moses
or admit that the Quran doesn't say that
anywhere.
So either of the two once you do either
of the two you can ask me whatever your
your how can I how can I screen share on
my uh on my uh what was it called? I
mean, how can I show my my my screen on
on their Tik Tok? You don't need to. I
mean, but you can you can just push, you
know, um push your profile and then push
the camera button.
How? No. No. Cuz basically, if I get
off, what is it called on TikTok? You
can't hear me. So, that's Do you need a
verse? Do you want me to pull up
something? What do you want me to look
at? All right.
Wait, wait. What? What? Do do you use
Google or uh what was it called? Um Chat
GP. Only I only use the Quran, brother.
All right.
I'm Quran only. I'm an original Quran
only Christian. I don't use no chat GBT.
I don't use no no CBD
uh chat GBT uh
LCD. It's got Logic in five.
5:44
544. Now, do me this favor, brother. You
just read 544. Did you read it yourself?
Yeah. Okay. It basically said, does it
say Wait, we sent down It says we sent
down the Torah. It says, "We sent down
the Torah and the prophets used it to
judge the Israelites." Right. All right.
All right. Does it say that? Does it say
who the Torah was given to? Which
prophet?
Bro, bro, don't don't don't do this,
bro. Like, actually, now you're taking
it. You're taking it uh you're doing it
too much. Like
Yeah. I I gave you three verses that you
have to understand about Moses being
sent Torah, but you never you never you
are trying not to believe about you are
trying not to believe that. It's crazy.
You think so? Yes. Okay. up. I'm I'mma
do you I'm gonna give you this chance,
man, because uh I like I like you, man.
You have a good personality. Um I I want
to give you a chance to maybe look this
over, think about it really quick,
reflect on it. Come back when you have
like um something substantial. Okay.
Hey, hey, bro. Yo, yo, can I ask you
like some questions like Nope.
Basically, I want to know about uh
something about I want I want you to
feel this feeling that you have. I want
you to know I want you to sit with this
feeling that you were unable to defend
Islam today. And that is going to that's
going to awaken something in you. It's
going to make you dive really deep into
Islam and really try to learn how to
defend it which then you'll see that
it's false and then you'll come to
Christianity by the Lord's grace. No,
bro. No, bro. Islam till I die, bro. I
I'll never come I'll never be a
Christian. I've I've heard that so many
times from people just like you and they
have converted live in front of my face.
Okay. Okay. Listen, but what's the uh
fastest growth religion right now? Um
Christianity. Nah. No, you are lying,
bro. Maybe set up right now. He is. No.
Go and set it up right now, bro. Like go
and set it up right now. Okay. Okay.
Okay. I'll take take care, man. I thank
you for coming, bro. No, bro. Please.
Please. No. No. Actually, go and set it
right now, bro. No, bro. Please, bro. I
can't I can't I can't just kick you like
this, but I I got to I got to move on,
bro. Nah, bro. Like, like just set it
up. Like, what was the fastest growth
religion? Please, bro. Please, please.
If you if if
my
heart my heart I didn't want to
disconnect with him like that, with him
pleading like that, but uh you know, I
just had to. It's tough love. Tough
love. Remember this mo. Remember this
moment. All right. Remember this moment.
Remember the moment that you went all
over the Quran, used chat GBT, pulled up
articles, and there was nothing in the
Quran that helped you out. There was
nothing that was able to answer this
question because Islam has no answers.
It's incomplete. Remember this moment.